you
my name is Horace Engdahl I'm the
permanent secretary of the switch
Academy and I have here beside me the
laureate for literature of the year 2008
Jean Marie Louise you I was speaking
English here brings us immediately on
the question of languages we were asked
by the director of the Nobel webservice
to do that and we have agreed but of
course your literal language is French
but apart from that which are your
language is you speak English because
your father was a British citizen you
also maybe speak Spanish because you
spent a lot of years in Mexico and have
read somewhere that at a certain stage
or your career you even learned in an
Emer engine language is that true yes
yes I personally I belong to a jewel
culture because my family is from
Mauritius and as you may know in
Mauritius the official language is
English the current language is Creole
and the literary language is French but
I do not speak Creole I speak very
little Creole I would not try to speak
with you in Creole and I would
understand it's Nucky's yes so I'm used
to shifting languages because my father
used to speak to us so my brother and I
used to speak in English he wanted us to
to be quite fluent in English especially
when he was he was trying to correct our
behavior 8 we do that in English and
then of course I have lived in other
countries in Latin America I learn to
speak the what they call the espanol
callejero the what's the Spanish from
the streets an auditory Spanish and
after that I live for some time in the
forest which is the Embera Indians
I had to learn some amber language which
is totally different from the
indo-european languages
you